- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Lily Ma
and my one word is extraordinary.
I believe that every human being
is capable of doing extraordinary things.
So to help you on your journey
today's message is follow your heart.
Over to you, Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I found that with depression,
one of the most important
things you could realize
is that you're not alone.
You're not the first to go through it
and you're not going to be
the last to go through it
and oftentimes it happens.
You just, you feel like you're alone
and you feel like it's only you
and you're in your bubble
and I wish I had someone at that time
who could just pull me aside,
"Hey, it's going to be okay.
"It's going to be okay."
So I wish I knew that.
We just got to remember,
hold on to that fundamental
quality of faith.
Have faith
and on the other side of your pain
is something good.
After about a month and a half
of staying in that little
apartment and cleaning,
I got a phone call from the head coach
of the team who cut me.
The head coach of the Calgary Stampeders.
He called me and he said,
"Hey, I know we cut you
"but I'd like you to come back."
I said, "Okay, I appreciate that, coach.
"Thank you very much.
"I'll think about it."
He said, "Okay, great."
I hung up the phone and my dad said,
"You going to do it, right?"
I said, "No, I don't think so.
"I think I'm done with that."
And he goes, "What?"
I said, "My gut tells me I'm done."
He said, "What are you going to do?"
I took a deep breath,
I said I'd like to get into the business.
And he said, "What business?"
And I said, "The wrestling business."
He says, "You are throwing it all away.
"It is the worst mistake
you'll ever make."
He said, "You're ruining your career."
"So maybe I'll be no good
"but I feel like in my
heart I have to do this
"and I either need you
"to train me
"or need you
"to not train me."
My dad rose to the occasion.
He said, "I'll train."
And it wound up being
one of the greatest chapters in my life.
- A lot of people don't
follow their heart.
Instead what they do is,
they look at a list of
things that could go wrong
and all the people who would
be disappointed at them
if it does go wrong.
And they end up talking themselves
completely out of this opportunity
that they have in front of them.
I precisely remember the moment
that Evan offered me to work
and mentor under him full-time
and he was just saying a lot of details
and all I could focus on was my heart.
My heart was saying, "Yes,
"I'm going to take on this opportunity."
But I still had to keep my composure
because I wanted him to go
through the details with me.
And honestly, that was
the first time in years
I actually followed my intuition.
I always pride myself as
someone who is very logical.
Every opportunity that came my way
I would make a list
of all the things that's involved.
I would make a list of all the people
that's going to be involved
and all the finances that are involved
and what I end up doing
is doing nothing at all.
I just sit and do nothing
and nothing happened with my life.
And soon all of that just amount
to a huge amount of regret.
Every single day I'm like,
"I'm going to regret not
taking on this opportunity
but yet I would just
overthink everything through
and I started to think about
when on my deathbed,
what would I do with all these regrets?
I didn't want to regret not
taking on opportunities anymore.
So before I even got a
chance to think about
the offer he gave me,
my heart just said yes and
I was going to take it on.
And I knew it was going to work out
'cause it felt right deep inside me.
Even though a lot of people
started questioning me
and said, "Well, you don't
really have a business plan.
"You don't even know what the plan is.
"You don't know if it's going to pan out."
And I just kind of sat back
and I thought to myself,
"No, it's going to work
out because I have faith
"that we're doing the right thing."
And I'm so glad that I
actually listened to my heart
and not my brain overthinking
things constantly
because every morning that I'd wake up
I am so fulfilled with my life
and I know every day
that I walk in and I work
I know I'm living out dream
and I'm not going to regret any of this.
So I challenge you,
next time you find yourself
at a crossroads of an opportunity,
don't overthink anything.
Just do and follow your heart.
So the question of the day is
when was the last time
you followed your heart?
I would love to read your comments
and I'll join in on the discussion.
So I have a special shoutout
for Felipe Palleros.
Felipe, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
Evan's book, Your One Word
and I hope you enjoyed
it as much as I did.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you
and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
and we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(keys clacking)
- Paul, when you first
signed up for the first one
which was back in '99, 2000?
And did you think you'd
be sitting here in 2013
talking about number six?
- No, not a chance.
No screenplay, nothing when I signed on.
It was just an idea.
- Yeah.
- It was funny because I wanted to do it,
working with my friends
'cause I'd already worked
with these people before
and they're like, "You can't do it."
My representatives were telling me,
"You can't do it.
"There's no script,
there's nothing" and then--
- You didn't listen to their advice.
- You were right.
- I got lucky.
But it was just,
following your heart kind of thing
and it wasn't even about down the road.
It was about living in the moment.
I got lucky.
- [Announcer] This young
dedicated artist can't help
but reflect on those who once doubted him.
- They never said I
wasn't talented enough.
They'd say something like,
"The industry is shady.
"You'll need to be doing this."
I respected their opinions
but at the end of the day
I had to follow my heart
and that's what I want to do with passion.
I couldn't shake it
and I'd be hurt now if
I didn't stick with it
'cause it'll always be on my head.
- What is it about investment
and entrepreneurship
that sort of has bitten you?
- I never look at it as
investments, believe it or not.
I just look at it as partnerships,
help changing the world
and just being part of
something that's inspiring.
My business people all the time,
whenever they talk about money,
you can ask them, I go, "Ah!"
I don't want to hear it but
if they bring an idea to me
that I think is going
to go to the next level,
most of the time if I follow
my heart
then everything else will fall in place.
I've never ever done a deal,
"Ey, we got this suit company.
"We throw some pinstripes in the suit.
"You give me a 100,000.
"We sell 20 of 'em we make."
I've never done a deal
where it was always based on money.
I've always done my business deals
based on how I felt it was
going to go in the future,
how I felt it was going to
help and inspire somebody.